ah
what the heck happened to it hey guys
it's max angelica and vadim and welcome
to our unbiased blind camera comparison
with the brand new s22 ultra against the
iphone 13 pro max and let me remind you
guys this is completely unbiased because
max actually took both phones yesterday
and he took 30 photos and we have not
seen any of them except for this first
one that's on the laptop so go ahead and
get out a piece of paper and a pen play
along with us write down your answers
and let us know in the comments yeah
make sure you guys do that it's always a
ton of fun and let's start out with this
first image we have our bearded dragon
spiky i'm noticing that the one on the
right is kind of like washed out in
terms of the colors and it looks like it
might be a little bit too bright at some
point so i'm choosing the left i also
don't see as much detail on the one on
the right by far and
s22 the s22 ultra definitely looks
better in every way we'll see if this is
the best smartphone in the world here
here's our second photo outside backlit
during sunset i would say the right one
is better because a lot of the details
on the left
are crushed i actually want to go with
the left one because i don't like how
the snow looks very blue on the right
and like the details kind of like faded
in terms of the colors and contrast all
right so you guys are disagreeing yeah
and vadim went for the samsung
angelica went for the iphone now here we
have an ultra wide shot
oh easy that one easy left it's so easy
the right one is so just crushed this is
almost like a silhouette one yeah but
the look the dynamic range isn't really
different actually this one might be
better that's really really sunset
really and you can still see noah and
that is a samsung oh it's cute anyway
three for samsung yeah
okay
and we have this shot right here
how's it look wow the bright one looks
amazing i already know what it is
because it's so good
yep exactly the right is the s22 ultra
the improved 10x wow i want to point out
though that when we did this last time
yeah i don't know if it was half a year
ago
uh or a year ago the iphone was terrible
horrible and they've actually improved
their algorithm since it came out we got
our first selfie here for me definitely
the one on the right the one on the left
just
there's no detail in their faces it's so
washed out i would also agree because
the one on the left it has no highlight
roll off on the faces it's like
completely flat no shadowing no lights
the one on the right is much more
accurate
exactly that way that is the samsung
five look at this selfie it looks
amazing and the dynamic range is better
up here too
all right we got the shot a wide shot
against the sun the left for sure
there's so much more
contrast and detail and dimension and
even though there's that huge flare on
it this one also does have a flare
there's like this big purple spot i'm
actually gonna go for the right because
they're very similar but the right one
does not have like a huge flare going
sideways and i also notice on the left
the trees are all crushed so i'm going
with the right
s22
so iphone even though they got rid of
some of the flaring it can still happen
where samsung they have those rings now
but no flaring and we have a portrait
shot right here with the sunset i'm
gonna go with the rights on this one for
a couple of reasons i feel like it's
more sharp
and it's not as flat in terms of the
contrast and i like how you can actually
see the sunset colors reflecting off of
her face and her hat whereas the other
one's flat i definitely agree the one on
the right looks so much better and also
i don't know if it's just me but it
seems like it's less
like distorted yeah oh yeah i agree yeah
this portrait is so much better
and that is the iphone finally one for
the team was that your first one yeah
on mac stack and he doesn't believe it
all right we got the shot of the tesla
i'm gonna go with the left simply
because i feel like the one on the right
is just too dark in terms of the detail
of the car i don't know i agree s22
ultra and look at that we don't have
that flare
that's right there messing up the car
shot
and then we have
a telephoto portrait with some nice
compression that's backlit i'm gonna
have to go with the
right again because you don't really
have that big of flaring you do have a
little bit and also the face has more
dimension in terms of highlight roll off
and shadows where this is like all flat
i disagree i feel like i feel like it's
pushed too far
with the contrast where it just does not
look realistic
i'm gonna have to go with the left
despite that
all right
again for me and here is a shot of some
buildings what can you guys see i see a
lot more detail on the left if you look
at the text it looks so sharp while the
right image just looks so fake so
processed yeah the right does look very
sharpened almost like yeah like
processed the left one looks more
natural but i wish it had a little bit
more contrast so which one's still gonna
go left
yeah you can always add a little bit of
contrast in
and that is the s22 ultra so there you
guys go you see that
that was a crop of the bridge section of
course the s22 ultra has a 108 megapixel
mode which is what i was using uh
compared to just 12 megapixels on the
iphone with some extra processing
and here we have our first video
samsung as you guys know has 8k video
where the iphone still is only at 4k so
let's go ahead and take a close
look right off the bat i'm really liking
the contrast sharpness and the color
reproduction on the right whereas the
left looks kind of i don't know soft and
just
definitely not as good so right is the
winner so far
some parts of it i noticed that the one
on the left looks more natural
like over here it looks like slightly
out of focus well that's more focused
where here everything looks
sharp yeah i mean the left is so soft so
right for sure so we have one that's 4k
and one that's 8k
so vadim's choosing the right what are
you choosing angelica easy i'm also
going for the right right yeah the
colors
and the hdr of it looks a lot better
and the right is actually the iphone 4k
and here's the trick beats 8k um the
iphone i actually had to crop in 50
digitally what because the s22 ultra
when you go into 8k it doesn't use the
full sensor it crops in
like 40 or so so on the iphone i had to
use digital crop to match up
that's crops so if you don't crop it
actually looks better than this
compared to the s22 so this that just
proves that pure pixels
that doesn't mean you're going to get a
better video quality because there's a
lot of processing hdr other stuff that
makes the image look better overall and
i probably would say that the 4k might
look better on the s22 ultra than their
ak once again
all right let's move on i'm going with
the right the one on the left just looks
too dark too crushed for me yep same
here i think all these details are too
crushed and kind of ruins it
s22 ultra and we got a portrait shot i'm
going with the left because the one on
the right is really bothering me because
right behind her it just gets so
blurred out it's completely unnatural
it's way too much blur completely agree
this looks
not real looks so fake
you guys chose the samsung samsung you
guys didn't notice but there's actually
no blur here at all
yeah nothing at all
uh it looks like the samsung
you can't do portrait mode if you're
standing that far away i tried it
multiple times the iphone let you and
they used to be backwards actually used
to be the iphone couldn't do it now
looks like the opposite but you guys
still chose the one you guys liked
better too much blur on that one yeah
and we have this extremely difficult
portrait shot portrait shot yep static
object with the trees there
i mean easily the left easily the left
because uh the colors sunset colors look
more natural especially like the uh
stone or concrete whatever the contrast
the contrast looks really good too
easily
i was surprised by
how
both of these did cutting out all these
tiny little things in all those trees in
the background so iphone takes it
because of color
and we got an ultra wide right here left
left instantly the left because the
color of the snow and also the sky is
not blown out look at this
s22 ultra that ultra wide looks
fantastic it's really good and we got a
selfie here back by the sunset what do
you guys think
that's insane which one should i keep
long term
the right one man the right one the
right one looks amazing blown out here
on the left the face is flat no
highlight roll off flat yeah easily the
right
samsung with their 40 megapixel selfie
camera killing it yeah that's incredible
and then we got this
the neon signs and this window with a
bunch of bright lighting right like the
right yeah
that looks great yeah the main thing is
that boo sign where it's not just
completely blown out so nice
that is the 13 pro max
so i guess a selfie sucks at hdr but
that rear camera does a killer job and
then we got a macro here and lower
lighting wow both go into macro mode
left yeah the one on the right is out of
focus looks like way out of focus
everything i mean everything's out of
focus
what's in focus
yeah
samsung looks much better in terms of
detail and also colors interesting
and then we got a pure nighttime shot i
mean this was pitch black i couldn't
even see elon
so we're in the night time now oh man
just the motion blur on both and he was
moving around on both of them was he uh
yep i feel like the left one doesn't
look as bad to me i feel like really i
mean look at the jacket you see some
detail here he's just a blob
i don't know
i'm gonna go
i guess i'll go left because even though
it has some noise
yeah there's a lot of like smearing and
like yeah look at his face here what is
that there's more detail everywhere
around him than him yeah it's kind of
weird
all right and the left is the iphone
here's one interesting thing for this
photo the iphone took two seconds
this one is like four seconds and most
of the nighttime photos the samsung took
way longer to take them and then we have
an indoor
darker lighting
portrait where you can use night mode
and portrait mode definitely the left
for me the right one so much details are
crushed way too contrasty i am also
going to go with the left because i
don't like how on the right her hair is
completely black it's just crushed and
she does not have black hair yeah
iphone takes the win for another
portrait here and then we have a food
shot that looks good
one of these phones have a food mode but
you can disable the blur the other one
just automatic
yeah left kills it you could actually
see all the detail in the sauce and the
herbs
that is the iphone definitely a more
natural
photo there and probably the deep fusion
kicking into that lighting
and then we have a nighttime super warm
lighting what do they call portrait shot
another portrait yeah the left
the right one in her face there's it's
so dark and there's
not much detail way more crushed yeah
also going with the left because on the
right her eyes just look so dark and
like shadows under her eyes you can't
really see her face and her expression
so you guys make some good points left
yeah that is the iphone again
so we are we're having some consistent
results with these phones here
and then we have a nighttime portrait
selfie in a very tough situation man the
left definitely the left the jackets so
much more detail this looks so flat and
washed out yep i also agree left because
there's a lot more detail on all the
jackets the codes even though like the
shadows are a little bit darker but it
still beats it yeah i agree once again
for the samsung doesn't matter what kind
of selfie you're taking or when they
look amazing
and we have our
second video okay
both of these are 4k
samsung made a big deal about their
nighttime videography knightography they
labeled it so let's take a look
oh my gosh that's disappointing
that's so disappointing ah
what the heck happened to it
oh
wow
what in the world this is like potato
camp
all right we're through what do you guys
think potato camp at first like in the
first still shot the left one looked
really good right and then as soon as it
starts playing it just oh my i mean yeah
let's play that like talking about it
the noise yeah it destroys it it just
stopped brighter it made everything
brighter everything's like blueish
purple
but you can see this better isn't that
good to see that
this is like a potato
yeah the one on the right detail color
no noise yeah ten times better all right
so right yep is iphone
this was actually the feature that i was
most looking forward to the
knightography and making everything
brighter at night
and maybe it's an improvement compared
to the previous one
but
the iphone just looks so so much better
and i would i would probably say that
maybe it's just because that 108
megapixel sensor that they have to
download from and process it's so much
work the pixel compared to just 12
megapixels
all right we got um a shot here it was
super super dark for this one i think
i'm gonna go with the right if i'm
looking close i see a lot more detail
especially like in the jeans and like
the
highlight roll off of his face whereas
the left is very flat the entire image
um i actually disagree i like the left
one more i feel like in the jacket i can
see more detail this looks kind of
smoothed out
and some of the dark parts are kind of
brought up the shoes everything and the
background here just looks
too
processed so saying this looks more
natural this looks more processed
interesting huh
and the iphone is more processed you
know what's funny we people always used
to make fun of samsung for being way
over processed and too contrasty but
what happened
yeah now that i the samsung's more
natural
and then we got this nighttime ultra
wide whoa
i agree that's what i thought well
i mean like on the left just
everything's bright but you can see
everything which is nice the one on the
right is probably more realistic to what
it was like but it's just so dark i'm
going with the left i'm also going with
the left
and that's samsung
yeah everything was actually darker than
even in this photo
but yeah you have so much detail there
and then we have this zoom shot that's a
crazy difference
whoa i mean look at that look at my
fresh basket you actually know the color
that's like crazy it's like white
both of these
those lines both of these were shot at
10x zoom 10x zoom okay 10x zoom here
yeah there's a interesting difference in
focal length too no the left is much
better like you don't have all that
compression noise artifacts ever you
don't have yeah left
and which one do you think
what do you think the left is i don't i
mean it makes sense for it to be the
samsung because it actually has a 10x
optical lens compared to 3x
all right guys
this one shocked me because that is the
iphone
wait how is that possible
i looked into the 3x lens i looked into
it and the truth is
when it's dark outside the samsung does
not use that 10x lens
because
this design it loses a lot of light it
needs super bright lighting to work well
so here what's it using 3x the 3x lens
so this is why is it so much worse
iphone's 3x lens versus samsung's 3x
lens and i think it all just goes uh for
processing
the processing is just terrible here and
look it's not even 10x it's set to 10x
look how much wider it is like fake 10x
uh an iphone in the last six months
since the iphone came out i noticed on
the zoom shots they've made it a lot
better with their algorithm all right we
have this shot right here same thing
look you actually get the green
washington the left looks so good so
moody look at these trees right here oh
yeah
that is the iphone once again oh my gosh
and that is also so this is a telephoto
shot this is actually just set to 3x
when i was shooting these i didn't know
that the 10x wouldn't work so i was
trying to use all the lenses and even if
you don't do digital crop that's just
the result now we have a really tough
portrait shot here
wow the one on the right because first
of all the left it's all orange and like
yellowish tint everything here you
actually have like differences in the
colors like the table the flowers stand
out looks more natural i was gonna go
with the left actually
and you guys are split vadim shows the
iphone angelica chosen samsung
and then we have this shot this might be
the last one sinatra nice oh it's very
dark we have a variety of things here
all right with this one i kind of feel
like i'm going with the right because
i'm looking really closely at the
details like the record has uh more
sharp details and i like how the blue
color is brought out more and i'm
disagreeing i'm actually going with the
left
i feel like the details pretty similar
and i do like the colors of the right
one but something about the right just
feels distorted to me it feels unnatural
this one seems a lot more natural and
then i would just bring up whatever
colors or contrast
and we have the s22 ultra for redeem on
the right and the iphone on the left
and on that is the last
one so this was a shocker
um so you guys let us know down below
how many you voted for each and if there
were any surprises we want to hear your
guys's comments yeah um these guys are
telling their um
their stuff up interesting
and who wants to go first team can go
first all right so
for the iphone
i have 13
17 for the s22
is that the biggest gap you've had
in the past usually it's pretty close
pretty i mean i'm impressed yeah
very good a lot of them angelica and for
me
i tied oh oh really
15 and 15 30 total interesting wow so
what were some surprises that we had
that close up with the 3x yeah the
iphone being way better that was a
shocker
a lot of the hdr seemed really good with
the samsung yeah like highlight roll-off
wise not being flat for all of the
lenses the ultra wide the main one the
selfie very good not flat for people but
also hdr is excellent yeah selfie camera
oh it's shocking like if you like taking
selfies
i think this is the best every selfie
was better yep yeah
i think okay video the video
though if you like shooting video
marketing
if you like shooting selfies and video
i'm sorry because the iphone blows away
the video quality
um and then the iphone's great for
portraits too for rear portraits it did
a really good job so there you guys go
there's our unbiased camera comparison
and it looks like
the samsung is a killer choice at least
for vadim it's good it's good definitely
it definitely has lots of improvements
compared to before they're both great
and overall
you can't really lose both of them are
pretty nice so there you guys go make
sure you guys are subscribed because
we're also doing another one with the
s22 ultra against the s21 ultra and note
20 ultra we'll see how much better is
this phone and is it worth upgrading to
check out one of those great videos
right over there that's been max
angelica and vadim and we will see you
in the next video
[Music]